in this video you will learn everything
about the leica scale
let's start with the most important
question why do we need a leica scale
let's assume you formulated a hypothesis
and there is a variable that you cannot
measure directly a so-called latent
variable
latent variables are for example
physical well-being or environmental
awareness
why are these variables not directly
measurable
of course you could simply ask in your
questionnaire
what is your level of environmental
awareness the problem is that by just
asking this one question
measuring environmental awareness is
very difficult or very inaccurate
the reason is that environmental
awareness consists of several dimensions
the first person might think about the
question well i'm a member of an animal
protection association and i take care
of distressed animals and maybe that
person therefore ticks very high but on
the other hand he or she makes a long
distance trip by plane three times a
year the next person thinks well my
environmental awareness is very high i
know that we should actually separate
the garbage we shouldn't drive the car
all the time so yes my environmental
awareness is very high but i don't
really care about it so does this person
then take high or low
so of course you can just ask this
single question to measure environmental
awareness but the answers would be quite
useless
now in order to still be able to
adequately measure latent variables like
environmental awareness
you use scales a scale is a group of
questions for example question 1 2 3 and
4
with answer categories from for example
true to not true these questions
together serve to measure a latent
variable by using multiple questions
your measurement becomes more accurate a
scale like this is also called a
multi-item scale the best known scale is
the leicad scale the leicad scale is a
method of measuring personal attitudes
this scale consists of several questions
so-called items
items are statements that record the
degree of agreement or disagreement of
the respondents respondents can thus
indicate how much they disagree or agree
with a statement on the response scale
typically a 4 or 5 level rating is used
the question if a middle category makes
sense or not cannot be answered in
general in some cases it makes sense for
the respondents to have a neutral middle
category available
in order to not be pushed in one
direction on the other hand there is a
risk that many respondents will be happy
to simply choose the middle category
which could make your results less
meaningful now the next question is how
do i come up with the right questions do
i just make the questions myself
that's not a good idea because in that
case you would first have to go through
the effort of checking whether your
questions really measure the latent
variables correctly the right way is to
do a literature and scale research
and find out if there are already
validated questions that you can use to
measure your variables what is the
easiest way to start a literature and
scale research we just start quick and
dirty and google our topic
the next question is how do you analyze
a leica scale the participants in your
survey have now ticked something from
applies to does not apply for questions
1 to 4.
now you can export the finished survey
to excel or data tab then in each row
there is a respondent and in the columns
there are the four questions the first
person check two for question one one
for question two three for question
three and two for question four now you
want to measure your latent variable
with these four questions for leica
scales matrix scale level is often
assumed in practice strictly speaking
the answers on a leicard scale are
ordinarily scaled because the distances
between the answers are not likely to be
perceived as equal by the survey
participants therefore the most common
way is that you build a so-called mean
index for this you simply calculate the
mean value of each row now you have an
estimate for your latent variable you
can also easily calculate the mean index
with data tab to do this copy your data
into this table and click on data
transformation
now you can click here and select
questions 1 to 4 then click on the mean
index and enter the name of the new
variable done
now you can check if your questions
really measure a latent variable you can
do this with the chromebox alpha if you
want to know more about it please have a
look at my video about chromebox alpha
thanks for watching